i don't want to remember what i was like
before
gwen actually if that answers your
question gwen stefani and blake shelton
are looking forward to some down time
now that they've wrapped up the latest
season of the voice
and they're ready to celebrate their
first christmas together as an engaged
couple
i'm so full of love a source tells e.t
that while 2020 has been tough for
everyone
gwen and blake have spent a lot of time
reflecting on what they're grateful for
quote with their recent engagement and
holidays coming up
they truly couldn't be happier gwen and
blake are excited about their first
christmas engaged and want nothing more
than to just
enjoy being together as a family the
source adds that the two are focusing on
staying safe
and isolating as the cases continue to
surge amid the coronavirus pandemic
they both laugh about the fact that they
never thought that staying home could be
so fun
but they're actually looking forward to
the downtime together again after
shooting the voice
it's incredible to have a best friend
like that guy
and speaking of the voice gwen she's
going into the holiday victorious
i think it's funny that i'm gonna win
the voice yep
she called it on tuesday team gwen won
season 19 of the voice
with contestant carter rubin being
crowned the champion
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations
on monday's live show the 15 year old
crooner sang his debut single
and covered miley cyrus's the climb
[Music]
and on tuesday he performed one last
time alongside his coach for
a special duet
[Music]
this marked gwen's first time winning
the show
how amazing is it to be my first win
ever i can't even speak i
you know the thing about winning is it's
not you don't really care until you
actually win
and then all sudden it really means a
lot but it's hard to take it in i just
feel so excited for carter because um
he's the first male at 15 to win the
voice and this is my first win and we're
on a global pandemic so this is a pretty
monumental moment
as for blake well he was a bit sore over
losing
i just beat blake shelton at the voice
okay just so you know
this show's rigged when it comes to
wedding planning
e.t source says the couple wants to
start planning their nuptials as soon as
the pandemic
is under control adding that gwen knows
blake is the perfect man for her
somebody that is humble
kind down to earth selfless
talented on the top of their game should
i keep going
[Laughter]
i think i'm his biggest fan quote she
has appreciated him from the moment she
met him but says their time together
during the pandemic has actually brought
them closer together
and made them both realize how lucky
they are to have found each other
blake recently opened up on the bobby
bone show about why it was important to
include both his family and
gwen's fam in their october proposal i
didn't want to take her away
you know or do something private away
from the kids i felt like it was
important for
the kids to be a part of that moment and
so that's that's what i did
just a little refresher gwen has three
kiddos whom she shares with her
ex-husband
gavin rossdale kingston zuma and apollo
the only thing that i had planned bobby
was that i
i knew that i wanted to do it uh in in
oklahoma while
her all her kids were there and her
brother
and his and his family and my sister and
her family we have a
like a group that we get together like
fourth of july's christmas
thanksgivings it's kind of turned into
this core group and it's been that way
for years
so i wanted everybody to be there
you